[Music]
tonight
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
strength it's a word we've heard a lot
this year
strength of the american people
strength it's a word we've heard a lot
this year
strength of the american people strength
of the american worker
strength of the american family we've
seen grit
determination optimism hope
we took the virus head on and now we're
getting back to a normal life
the second shift the dance lessons and
friday night football
but some want to tear us down they don't
believe in america's promise
their ideas would kill jobs and drag
down our economy
we'll never give up on america not now
not ever because now is a time to renew
our faith
restore our safety rebuild our economy
to keep winning we've faced our toughest
challenge and we are overcoming just
like we always do
because we believe in america
every night in my dreams
i see you i feel you
that is
[Music]
between us
you have come to show
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
my heart will go
[Music]
love can touch us one time
and last
[Music]
love was when i loved you
one true time i know
what truly matters is
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
my heart will go
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i there's that my heart will go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are my fire
the one desire
believe when
i say i
wanted that away
but are we
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
tell me
oh
tell me
[Music]
[Music]
say
[Music]
i want you to know
[Music]
desire you are
[Music]
hey
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
i
[Music]
america demanded change donald trump
wins the presidency and change is what
we got
under president trump america is
stronger
safer and more prosperous than ever
before wow
look at that the economy growing at a
record 33.1 percent
these numbers are absolutely remarkable
latinos and women saw the biggest
decreases in unemployment rates
and ladies and gentlemen the best is yet
to come
[Music]
ground control to major tom
[Music]
ground control to major tom
take your protein pills and put your
helmet on
[Music]
commencing countdown engines one
to check ignition and make god's love
[Music]
this is
[Music]
now it's time to leave
this is made to come to ground control
i'm stepping through the doors
[Music]
and the stars look very different
is
[Music]
[Music]
i'm feeling very scared
[Music]
tell my wife
[Music]
there's something wrong can you hear me
can you hear me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
katrina pearson
so the president heard some patriots
were coming to town
and he looked at that and saw all you
people
online and all the pictures and the
videos and
guess what now he wants to be here with
you
because he is the president of the
people
for many years americans have taken the
back seat
to politicians to special interests
and then came donald j trump
and they couldn't believe it because we
finally had
someone that was gonna put america first
and i gotta admit i don't think they
thought he'd really do it
but you know what they found out the
hard way
donald trump doesn't play those games
because he doesn't owe anyone for
getting him here because
you put him right here in the white
house
not once but twice
we were all there through this 2020
election cycle
we've seen these crowds
unlike you know joe biden and his six
hula hoops
the guy couldn't even get a thousand
views online but we're supposed to
believe
that he had more votes than barack obama
i mean come on nobody really believes
this crap
but hey there's something going on at
the capitol today
and i don't think they can hear you
this movement started over a decade ago
do i have any tea party people in the
house
and even if they think for a
second that they're going to get away
with it today
they got another thing coming
because today is just a day
and today is just the beginning
i have probably crossed paths with all
of you over the last 10 years
but i think those politicians down there
the republican politicians down there
have forgotten what the tea party
movement did
back then see they forgot
that americans know their rights
americans will stand up for themselves
and protect their rights
and they will demand that the
politicians that
we elect uphold those rights or we will
go
after them
so you better believe oh the next two
years
we are watching today we are taking
names today
and i don't know are you guys going to
forget
because today moving forward
we have hundreds of days for them to
hear from us
for them to see us and for them to work
on replacing them one
by one if we have to
president has sacrificed everything for
this country and has asked for
nothing in return
he loves the united states
of america
[Music]
he loves god he loves our flag
and he loves all of you
and that's why we're all here today
we love trump
and i gotta tell you i've never seen
someone
fight so hard so strong
against everything here and abroad
just to provide and protect
our basic values and principles that
keep our nation
free and are people able to go to
church
because they have forgotten at the end
of the day
these politicians are not in charge they
govern
at the consent of the people
we are revoking that consent moving
forward and we are going to
fight for our president we're going to
fight for our country and i guarantee
you
in two years every politician that
turned their back on our country
will lose their seat including
democrats
so i am so excited to be here with all
of you
being one of the original founders of
the tea party movement
traveling to every state in this country
meeting grassroots over the last 12
years
has truly been my honor to do everything
that i can
to make your voices heard
and i pledge to continue to doing that
for all of you for our children and our
grandchildren because here's the deal
guys
the left they go out there and they
scream and cry and they whine
but let me tell this is something they
don't get either
let me tell you they haven't seen a
resistance
until they have seen a patriot fight for
their country
[Applause]
because we know how to fight for our
country and we're not going to complain
we're not going to
we're not going to cry in the streets
we're not going to go sit in you're
going to see us
and you're going to hear us but we're
going to be working
we're going to fight in our state
legislatures to get rid of electronic
voting
we want ballots we want election
integrity we want to restore
the vote in our country because we all
know
they all know this election
was severely compromised
and we're going to make sure that that
never happens again
[Music]
because i can see from here all the way
back
there are more of us than there are of
them
and they're about to see us coming
so god bless you all for coming out here
and i am just so honored to introduce
your next speaker
she is a woman that i have known for a
very long time
who has fought for our country been a
voice for liberty have stood up
for all of those republican candidates
that the establishment tried to fight
tried to out fund and in some cases even
supported
democrats to keep a conservative
liberty republican out of this city
amy kramer is a woman
who has this amazing organization
called women for america first
but she was also the 2016
leader of women for trump
she is fierce she is a fighter
and after this election she took to the
streets because that's what we do as
patriots we
fight we don't sit around and wait for
politicians to act
or judges to act we the people
are in control of the united states and
we are going to remind
everyone that we are still a
constitutional republic
and we will take our rights back
over the last two months this woman has
traveled
over 14 000 miles on this big red bus
called march for trump have you heard
about it
going from city to city town to town in
the snow
in the rain working desperately
to fight for all of you to give you a
voice ladies and gentlemen
today we are all in this together
in this fight to restore america we will
save
america and amy kramer has been on the
front lines and it is my pleasure
to announce my friend and my sister
in liberty amy kramer
hello deplorables
oh my god decide to see i mean like
katrina said
as far back as i can see and i guess on
all the side streets
you know this president hasn't asked for
much from us he's asked for our vote
and he asked us to show up today and i
don't think he's going to be
disappointed
[Music]
you know there's so much at stake today
we
have been in the streets the past two
months there's a movement that has been
born
i come from the tea party movement and
i'm asked all the time
what happened to the tea party well
we're still here
we just grew and morphed into something
bigger and better the mega movement
and i am convinced that we're not for
the tea party movement
we would not have president donald j
trump today
he has fought for us and he unlike any
other president in our lifetime
has put america first and how refreshing
is that we love him i know you do i just
heard you chanting it
and he loves us he is putting our
country and the american people first
and washington doesn't like it why
because they're in the back pockets of
china and russia and ukraine
we've got their number we know what
they're doing and i don't care what they
say
sleepy joe biden did not win this
election
i come from the great state of georgia
that we're learning just how corrupt we
are right now
but sunday night before election day i
was in this little northwest town
of rome georgia we got there about noon
that day and we saw
thousands of people walking a mile over
a mile to go see our president
he was doing five rallies that day and
rome georgia was the fourth one i think
he showed up there at 8 30 9 o'clock
that night
but all day we watch these men and women
two and three generations of families
walking pushing elderly people in their
wheelchairs
elderly people on their walkers carrying
their children on their shoulders
all to see the president of the united
states and they
turned people away i think the the
auditorium or the
airport took 40 000 people that night
and they turned people away
and after it was over we watched them
leave the airport and it took hours
tears running down their faces their
children asleep on their shoulders
carrying their children walking people
didn't get home until two or three in
the morning
the press likes to talk about how the
people were stranded
no those people weren't stranded they
came there to see the president
it took him longer to get in than to get
out and it was worth
every moment to see the president of the
united states
and we're seeing the same here thing
here again today
but the thing is you can't convince me
after seeing those people in the crowds
of that
that day and all those rallies leading
up to election day
you can't convince me that a man who
can't fill six
circles won this election there is no
way
and as i look out here today this is
probably the biggest party that the
people have ever held for a president in
the history of this country
hold your signs up let us see your signs
you are amazing patriots amazing
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
the media says
they can call him president-elect that
doesn't make it so
right we know that there was voter fraud
we absolutely know it and that's why
we're here to stop the steal
first they say there's no voter fraud
then they say there's no widespread
voter fraud
so they they can say that there's no
voter fraud
but see we know that there is we know
that in pennsylvania 200 000 ballots
more than 200 000 ballots were returned
that weren't set out
we know there's voter fraud in georgia
do you know yesterday
that suitcases were sold out across the
state of georgia
and look what happened last night just
because the media doesn't tell you
what's going
on doesn't make it make it not true
right one of president trump's legacies
is his exposure of the fake news media
but that doesn't just mean
wrong and inaccurate information it's
also the omission of information
right but we're smarter than them
we've connected in other ways we've
connected via social media
and now big tech is trying to silence us
facebook has shut us down we're the
group
that started the stop the steel facebook
group the day after the election and
within 22 hours
it had over 365 000 members
and when they shut it down 1.2 million
members in the queue waiting to be added
that's amazing they've never seen
anything like it in the tech world
then mailchimp shuts us down so we can't
communicate with our supporters
and then eventbrite shuts us down but
they didn't just shut us down
they returned all of the donations and
then sent emails to everybody that had
signed up
telling them that had been canceled but
guess what
that didn't stop you that didn't stop
the people
we showed up on november 14th
because we love this country and we
love the president of the united states
they thought they were going to silence
us they thought they were going to stop
us
but then we came back again december
12th
and another approximately one and a half
million people showed up in washington
d.c
not because they thought they were going
to hear from president trump or see
president trump not because they thought
they were going to hear from somebody
with a trump last name
but because they love this country and
they love this president
and they are committed to standing for
election integrity
and saving our republic
so women for america first decided to
get on a bus
the march for trump bus and go across
america
and to take a little piece of everybody
we came across and bring it here today
to washington d.c
like i said the president has not asked
for much but he asked us to show up
today and we showed up
and we are not going to back down we're
not going away
you see republicans for years
have been afraid of their own shadow
they tuck tail and run
anytime they see their shadow if nothing
else what republicans should have
learned
is how to go on offense and win
and fight back punch back from donald
trump
he doesn't back down he's not afraid of
republicans he's not afraid of democrats
he doesn't need anybody else's money he
is fighting for me
and you and americans across this
country and he needs us now
just like we need him
so for years as the republicans over at
the capitol have been telling us they've
been fighting for us
what have they been doing they've been
crafting the terms
and finding a way our rights
that's what they've been doing and they
keep atta
attacking our president and you know
every time they attack him it's an
attack on you and i
and i don't know about you but i'm sick
of it
so we are here we're not going anywhere
we're not going to let them steal an
election
because this isn't about stealing an
election from donald j
trump this is about stealing an election
from we the people
and we are here to save the republic
you guys we can not back down
this is just the beginning we have a lot
of work to do
you
we are not gonna back down are we
keep up the fight keep fighting for
america it's worth saving
i don't know about you but i don't want
to learn to speak chinese and i don't
want that white house to turn red
[Music]
it is up to you and i to save this
republic and i am committed to doing
that
and i look forward to working with all
of you
across this nation for the next two
years and
let republicans know we're coming for
you
and democrats too
and before i go i just want to thank the
women for america first team they've
done an amazing job
they're not all up here today but we put
in long hours on those buses
four weeks on the buses spit christmas
away from our families
but it was all worth it we do it again
in a heartbeat we're not going to stop
fighting
and we'll see you out on the trail god
bless you all
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome from
the great state
of georgia representative jones
[Music]
hello america
hello america
hello for donald trump
i'm honored to be here today and i want
you to know i stand tall
and i stand firm and i'll stand with our
president of the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
he has been fighting for us he has been
fighting for america
and that's why we're here today to show
him that we are going to fight
for him
we're going to send a message to joe
biden nancy pelosi
chuck schumer and the entire democratic
party
they don't know they just have awakened
a sleeping giant
this party the gop is the grand old
party
but you know what we're about to make
this
the grand new party
we're going to bring in new ideas
we're going to bring in brand new people
and we're going to come in and we're
going to take our country back
we believe in the traditional values of
the constitution
we are going to protect all of our
members and clearly the second amendment
i am so fired up for what happened in
georgia and what happened across this
country
i've been thinking a lot
i'm ready to go home
i'm ready to go home to the party of
lincoln
i'm ready to go home to the party of
frederick douglass
i'm ready to go home to the party
of south carolina senator tim scott
today i'm coming home i'm coming home to
the grand old party
i am officially joining the republican
[Applause]
party
mike lindell i want to thank you for all
you've done
to influence me to support me
and give me the courage through my
trials and tribulations
fighting those demon democrats
i want to make clear about one thing
donald trump has just begun i'm a part
of his team
and we're going to take back this
country we're going to take back america
peace out america
now grab the general wait for the voice
of god
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
general paxton
accompanied by senator paxton
it is so awesome to be here i want you
to know
that texas fights we fought
12 straight lawsuits related to mail-in
ballots
related to signature verification
federal court state court travis county
austin
houston we fought we won every single
one of those cases
and because of that donald trump won
texas by over 600 000 votes
and thank god for a legislature in texas
like
my senator angela paxton my wife who put
in place
laws that protect against fraud
one of the great things about the state
of texas is that we did not we did not
quit
if you look at what georgia did they
capitulated they consented
we kept fighting in texas and then
we had the opportunity to go fight in
other states
and we sued four states over the ballot
fraud
and not following the constitution not
following state law
and we took it directly to the supreme
court and they should have heard our
case
and let me just finish up by saying
that what we have in president trump is
a fighter
and i think that's why we're all here we
believe in what he's accomplished over
the last four years
we were and because we're here today the
message goes on
we will not quit fighting we're texans
we're texans
we're americans and we're not quitting
god bless you for being here today
god bless this great country we live in
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't change
[Music]
for my
[Music]
in my hands
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
eric trump
good morning america
how you guys doing
this is the greatest group of patriots
ever put together
guys there is a person in the white
house right there my father the 45th
president of the united states
who i promise will never ever
ever stop fighting for you never
and we as a family will never ever stop
fighting for you we love this country
we love red white and blue we love
everything that this nation stands for
and guys that's why we fight
that's why my father sends out a tweet
patriots descend on washington
d.c and you look at the crowds out here
today it's absolutely incredible
i've got a question for you is there any
person here
that actually thinks that joe biden won
this election
i don't either guys i don't either you
know i went all across the country
everywhere i go this guy couldn't fill
up
a classroom and look at these crowds
here
look at these crowds here he hides in
his basement no one buys it guys no one
buys it
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
they can lie they can cheat
they can steal my father has started a
movement and
this movement will never ever die he
will never die
this is a movement that will transcend
him it's a movement that will transcend
all of us
and guys we are going to keep america
great because we live in the greatest
country in the world and we will never
ever ever stop fighting
[Music]
so i want to call up one person who's
been a great fighter she happens to be
my beautiful wife
and i'm going to publicly put her on the
spot right now
and tell her that she needs to run for
senate honey i'm just kidding
would anybody approve of that
that's pretty good honey
hey everybody how y'all doing
ladies and gentlemen let me just say
this you might hear otherwise from the
mainstream media
you might hear otherwise from the
democrats this
fight has only just begun
let's be very very clear about that and
eric said it
our family didn't get in this fight for
just four years
we are in this fight to the bitter end
we are gonna
take our country back okay
and before we go there's something very
important
that i want to make sure everybody knows
today today happens to be
my husband's birthday
honey do you have any birthday present
you would like from the united states of
america
well i'd actually i have one birthday
present that i want from all the
senators
and all the congressmen have some
backbone
show some fight learn from donald trump
he has more fight in them than every
other one combined
and they need to stand up and we need to
march on the capitol today
and we need to stand up for this country
and we need to stand up for what's right
we love you america god bless you all
can you guys help me sing happy birthday
to my husband
happy birthday
happy birthday to you
thank you guys we love you
let's keep the fight going america thank
you
kimberly get up here does anybody know
the great kimberly guilfoyle
we love her she's been such a warrior
she's fought so hard
take it away kimberly
well good morning d.c and good morning
america
how do we feel this morning and how much
do we love
president trump
here's the best news look at all of us
out here
god loving freedom loving
liberty loving patriots that will not
let them steal this election
president trump has been the most
transformative impactful president this
incredible country has ever seen
he is a great patriot that is fought for
the america
first policies for the american dream
for
you and your families thank you
president
trump
and we will continue to hold the line
across this incredible country because
we
finally had a president in the white
house that knows what it means to put
america first a president that
understands what it means
to have open schools not open borders
who restored the greatness of the
american military
who stands for veterans who stands for
law enforcement
and the american family
he is the president that humiliated the
democratic machine
in 2016 and turned the swamp
upside down and he will continue to
fight for that dream he will continue
to save america we will continue to
stand
for president trump stand with them and
for this country
we will not allow the liberals and the
democrats
to steal our dream or steal
our elections
[Music]
no president has fought harder than
president trump and his incredible
family and it's been an honor to stand
and fight alongside them
and we have a president that understands
what it means to stand for the second
amendment
for your rights for the constitution to
stand for life
and it gives me great pleasure to be
able to stand and fight
throughout this country with one of the
greatest americans i have the pleasure
to know
and that is donald trump jr the
president's son
let's give him a warm welcome and let's
show the president when he comes how
much we love him
god bless america god bless our
president
and ladies and gentlemen the best is yet
to come
[Music]
hello patriots
hey guys you actually all did something
i didn't realize was possible
i'm looking at the crowd here and the
tens of thousands probably hundred
thousand plus people here
and you did it all without burning down
buildings
you did it without ripping down churches
without looting
i didn't know that that was possible
according to the media
when you have a large gathering of
peaceful protesters they're supposed to
burn it all down
see guys we can do it right but the fact
that you are all here on this
rather cold january day
tells me all i need to know and it
should be a message to all the
republicans
who have not been willing to actually
fight the people
who did nothing to stop this deal
this gathering should send a message to
them
this isn't their republican party
anymore
this is donald trump's republican party
this is the republican party that will
put
america first
this is the republican party that will
fight
for the american worker
this is the republican party that's not
just going to roll over and die
because the democrats would like you to
no we've seen that guys we've seen that
we've been our own worst enemy
all you got to do is look to georgia
where you had republicans saying well
well i don't like the way the game is
played so let's take our ball and go
home
no guys hey guess what that was music to
chuck schumer's ears
that was music to nancy pelosi's ears
and that is what so many in the
republican establishment have created
that sort of mentality okay
we'll turn the other cheek we'll roll
over and die
we'll fold and give up
no more
so to those republicans many of which
may be voting on things in the coming
hours
you have an opportunity today
you can be a hero
or you can be a zero
and the choice is yours but we are
all watching
the whole world is watching folks
choose wisely
because if you just roll over if you
don't
fight in the face of glaring
irregularities statistical
impossibilities
that's right guys that's the message
these guys
better fight for trump because if
they're not guess what
i'm gonna be in your backyard in a
couple of months
guys like scott here look at wow
okay i can't go through the whole list
because i don't have 45 minutes to go
through all the patriots
that have been fighting that have been
on the ground that have mobilized
to put good republicans in those
positions guess what folks
if you're gonna be the zero and not the
hero
we're coming for you and we're gonna
have a good time doing it
[Music]
we gotta start fighting like the
democrats do
right we gotta play their game we gotta
take their fight to them
their way our reluctance to do that over
the last few decades is why
we are in the position that we are in
so today
friend or foe today republicans you get
to pick a side
for the future of this party
again i suggest you choose wisely
so kimberly thank you for all of your
fight how'd kimberly do folks
one of the great fighters out there uh
to my family to my father but most
importantly
to all of you red-blooded patriotic
americans
thank you for being in this fight with
us
thank you for standing up to the
[ __ ]
right amen and
and a woman
right
now yeah i know i know
but but that shows you literally
the mentality of where the democrat
party is right
i think i put it up on my instagram
which is being censored to hell right
now but like
i put it up yesterday they spent money
on a study that came to the incredible
conclusion yesterday
that trans women
playing in female sports have a
competitive advantage
no [ __ ] who could have seen that coming
i had no idea i'm glad we spent
probably millions figuring that out
just like i'm thrilled that we spent 10
million to pakistan on gender studies
because i'm sure they care
and billions elsewhere on nonsense
that is driven by the insanity of the
left folks
and we have to stand up for it
no one cares how you identify but you
don't have to do the nonsense that
follows
and what i want to know is in these
sorts of things where are the people
where are the feminists that we're
fighting as
men are dominating women's sports where
are they folks
we need to be the party of common sense
we need to be the party of reason
we need to be the party of our
values that we hold so dear that made
america the greatest country in the
world
and you guys are part of that movement
so stay
in this fight stay loud
don't be suppressed don't be put in your
corner
don't let them cancel you trust me i've
been canceled 17 times since i started
this speech i promise you
once it happens it's rather freeing and
you can kind of do what you want
don't let them do it to you stand up and
fight
stand up and hold your representatives
accountable and when you do
we can keep america great
thank you patriots thank you america
keep fighting thank you guys
[Music]
you'll make it back somehow
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Music]
always
you can best believe that he's a macho
man
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
mr
hey
all right
[Music]
all right
uh
is
uh
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
congressman madison
cawthorne
wow this crowd has some fight in it i am
so thankful that each and every single
one of you
come you know i just rolled down from
the capitol building about two miles
away down pennsylvania avenue
and i will tell you the courage that i
see in this crowd
is not represented on that hill
my friends i will tell you right now
that there is a new republican party
rising
the founders of our great country saw to
it
that the people who consent to be
governed should have a
voice in that government but my friends
the democrats with
all the fraud they have done in this
election
the republicans hiding and not fighting
they are trying to silence your voice
make no mistake about it they do not
want you to be heard
but my friends when i look out this
crowd i can confidently say
this crowd has the voice of lions
there's a new republican party on the
rise that will represent this country
that will go and fight in washington d.c
i'll tell you
i see so many of my friends who are up
in congress with me who are about to go
back to that capitol hill
and at 12 o'clock today we will be
contesting the election
but my friends bear in mind there is a
significant
portion of our party that says we should
just sit idly by and sit on our hands
they have no backbone
my friends i encourage you continue to
make your voice heard because
do we love donald trump
but my friends we're not doing this just
for donald trump
we are doing this for the constitution
our constitution was violated you know
if i knew that a city clerk in a city
called with
my name named madison can overturn a
state legislator and
alter the course of an election well
hell i might have ran for a different
office
my friends i encourage you go back to
your states after today
hold your representatives accountable
make sure that they stood up for
election integrity
and make your voices heard
my friends i want you to chant with me
so loud that the cowards on
washington dc that i serve with can hear
you while i leave let's get a chance so
donald trump knows who supports him
usa usa usa
usa usa usa
thank you all god bless
is
i've got to be
told me
oh
frankly senator sanders senator warren
and myself
are all on the same team what are you
willing to sacrifice
to make sure that over-funded police
departments are deep funded
there is no middle road on the climate
crisis i not only support a green new
deal i don't think it goes far enough
i'm all for a green new deal this is
part of what gun registration
is about we want to track where the guns
are we need to cut the defense budget
either chick-fil-a
are you in favor of expanding the court
or
perhaps an age limit in place instead of
a lifetime appointment
i've said everything is on the table
but if we win the majority everything is
on the table
now we take georgia then we change
america
change is coming to america the blue
wave is
comprised of those who are documented
and undocumented we win these races in
georgia so that we
don't have to negotiate
that's their goal total radical control
to bring horrific change to america
only georgians can stop them nobody can
serve
god and the military rafael warnock
attacks our military
police power the kind of gangster
and thug mentality warnock attacks
our police somebody's gotta open up the
jails
raphael warnock is dangerous no wonder
he defended this
not god bless
now america hope is that uh in early
january democrats will pick up
two more seats in the georgia runoffs uh
and that will make our life a lot easier
we need to send the message
this year we need to send the message
that if you
indulge this kind of politics you're not
just going to get beat
you're going to get beaten so bad you
can never run or show your face again in
public
because absolutely enough
of what we are getting from donald trump
and his fellow travelers right now
you're not just gonna get beat you're
gonna get beaten so bad he can never
run or show your face again in public
do
[Music]
[Music]
me
hear me
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
america's mayor
rudy giuliani accompanied by professor
john eastman
hello hello everyone
we're here uh just very briefly to make
a very important
two points number one
every single thing that has been
outlined
as the plan for today is perfectly legal
i have professor eastman here with me to
say a few words about that
he's one of the preeminent
constitutional scholars in the united
states
it is perfectly appropriate given the
questionable constitutionality
of the election counting
act of 1887 that the vice president
can cast it aside and he can do what
a president called jefferson did
when he was vice president
he can decide he can decide on the
validity
of these crooked ballots or he can send
it back
to the legislatures give them
5 to ten days to finally finish
the work we now have letters from five
legislatures
begging us to do that
they're asking us
georgia pennsylvania arizona
wisconsin
and one other coming in
so it seems to me
we don't want to find out three weeks
from now
even more proof that this election was
stolen
do we so
it's perfectly reasonable and fair
to get 10 days and you should know this
the democrats and their allies
have not allowed us to see one machine
or one paper ballot now if they ran such
a clean election
why wouldn't they make all the machines
available immediately
if they ran such a clean election they'd
have you come in and look at the paper
ballots
who hides evidence
criminals hide evidence not honest
people
so over the next 10 days
we get to see the machines that are
crooked
the ballots that are fraudulent and if
we're wrong
we will be made fools of but if we're
right
a lot of them will go to jail
so
let's have trial by combat
i'm willing to state i'm willing to
stake my reputation
the president is willing to stake his
reputation
on the fact that we're going to find
criminality there
is joe biden willing to stake his
reputation
that there's no crime there no
also last night one of the experts that
has examined
these crooked dominion machines
has absolutely what he believes is
conclusive proof
that in the last 10 percent 15 percent
of the vote counted
the votes were deliberately changed by
the same algorithm
that was used in cheating
president trump and vice president pence
same algorithm same system same thing
was done with the same machines
you noticed they were ahead until the
very end right
then you noticed there was a little gap
one was ahead by three percent
the other was ahead by two percent and
gone
gone they were even he can take you
through that and
show you how they program that machine
from the outside
to accomplish that and they've been
doing it for years
to favor the democrats it is a matter of
scientific proof
we need two days to establish that
it'd be a shame if that gets established
after it's over wouldn't it be
this was the worst election in american
history
this election was stolen in its seven
states
they picked states where they had
crooked democratic cities
where they could push everybody around
and it has to be vindicated
to save our republic this is bigger than
donald trump
it's bigger than you and me it's about
these monuments
and what they stand for this has been a
year
in which they have invaded our freedom
of speech
our freedom of religion our freedom to
move
our freedom to live i'll be daunted that
they're going to take away our free and
fair vote
and we're going to fight to the very end
to make sure that doesn't happen
let me ask professor eastman
to explain as
easily as we can i know this is
complicated but what happened last night
how they cheated and how it was exactly
the same
as what they did on november third
america's mayor wonderful
hello america
sorry i had to say that look we've got
petitions pending before the supreme
court that identify
in chapter and verse the number of times
state election officials
ignored or violated the state law in
order to put
vice president biden over the finish
line we know there was fraud traditional
fraud that occurred
we know that dead people voted but we
now know because we caught it live
last time in real time how the machines
contributed to that fraud
and let me as simply as i can explain it
you know the old way was to have a bunch
of ballots
sitting in a box under the floor and
when you needed more you pull them out
in the dark of night
they put those ballots in a secret
folder in the machines
sitting there waiting until they know
how many they need
and then the machine after the close of
polls we now know who's voted
and we know who hasn't and i can now in
that machine
match those unvoted ballots with an
unvoted voter and put them together in
the machine
and how do we know that happened last
night in real time
you saw when it got to 99 of the vote
total
and then it stopped the percentage
stopped but the votes didn't stop
what happened and you don't see this on
fox or any of those stations but the
data
shows that the denominator how many
ballots remain to be counted how else do
you figure out the percentage that you
have
how many remain to be counted that
number started moving up
that means they were unloading the
ballots from that secret folder
matching them matching them to the
unvoted voter
and voila we have enough votes to barely
get over the finish line
we saw it happen in real time last night
and it happened on november 3rd as well
and all we are demanding of vice
president pence
is this afternoon at one o'clock he
let the legislatures of the state look
into this
so we get to the bottom of it and the
american people know whether we have
control of the direction of our
government
or not
[Applause]
we no longer live in a self-governing
republic if we can't get the answer to
this question
this is bigger than president trump it
is the
very essence of our republican form of
government and it has to be done
and anybody that is not willing to stand
up to do it does not
deserve to be in the office it is that
simple
god bless you
and thank you so much for your support
i know the courage it takes to be out
there
i know how you get ridiculed i know how
they try to take jobs away from you but
you look in the mirror
every night and you say to yourself i'm
doing the right thing
for myself for my family for my children
and most importantly for the united
states of america
what truly matters is not which party
controls our government
but whether our government is controlled
by the people
[Music]
for too long a small group in our
nation's capital
has reaped the rewards of government
while the people
have borne the cost
[Music]
the establishment protected itself
but not the citizens of our country
[Music]
that all changes starting right here
and right now
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
what it means
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
can you feel it coming in
[Music]
[Music]
i've seen your face before
but i don't know who i am
[Music]
i know where you've been
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the last time
[Music]
the pain is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hold on
[Music]
wow
is
huh
[Music]
oh
my
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
saturday
foreign
but she was more like a movie
is
dreams
people always told me be careful what to
do
[Music]
is
she says
do a dance
just remember to always
is
[Music]
oh
she
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[ __ ]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
he took
[Music]
a singer in a smokey room
[Music]
it goes on and on and on
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did not feel
[Music]
some will lose
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
like
[Music]
don't stop
[Music]
my
[Music]
ain't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
now i've heard there was a secret court
that david played and it pleased the
lord
but you don't really care
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
[Music]
you say i took the name in vain
i don't even know the name
but if i did well really
what's it to you
there's a blaze of light in every word
it
doesn't matter what you heard
the holy
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
i did my best it wasn't much
i couldn't feel so i tried to touch
i've told the truth
and even though it all went wrong i'll
stand before
the lord
[Music]
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
somehow i think you've got to slow down
you really don't remember
[Music]
all the voices in your head
[Music]
why is
[Music]
morning
[Music]
hurry
[Music]
but you up don't remember
[Music]
now
[Music]
don't believe it's coming back soon
[Music]
[Music]
you don't have no answers
[Music]
that you've been living under
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
and they made a change
and it seems to me you lived your life
but i was just here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
was that maryland was found in the new
and it seems to me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
to hold yourself
never knowing
but i was just
[Music]
we can go
[Music]
[Music]
but you wanna be
[Music]
is
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you must have seen her
dancing in the sand
[Music]
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
jesus freaked
out in the street
handing tickets i've gone
[Music]
is
[Music]
looking on she sings the song
the word she knows
[Music]
and you can't hear me
when i stay softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
in
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
she's so blind
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you must see
[Music]
now she's in me
always with me
a tiny dancer
[Music]
softly
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
in the morning
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
he's never too stressed
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
is
hey
is
hey
not so much
[Music]
just a small town girl
[Music]
[Music]
he took
[Music]
yes
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
feel
just
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you're always
all the voices in your head
[Music]
[Music]
if everybody wants
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how's it going
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
no no no i am
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th
president of the united states of
america
president donald j trump
[Music]
[Music]
god
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
where there's pride in every american
heart
at a time
[Music]
today
[Music]
god
me
[Music]
today yes
um
[Music]
[Music]
and i saw thousands of people here but
you don't see hundreds of thousands of
people behind you because they don't
want to show that
we have hundreds of thousands of people
here and i just want them to be
recognized
by the fake news media turn your cameras
please
and show what's really happening out
here because
these people are not going to take it
any longer
they're not going to take it any longer
go ahead turn your cameras please would
you show they came from all over the
world actually but
they came from all over our country
i just really want to see what they do i
just want to see how they're covered
i've never seen anything like it
but uh it would be really great if we
could be covered fairly by the media the
media is the biggest problem we have as
far as i'm concerned
single biggest problem the fake news and
the big tech
big tech is now coming into their own we
beat them four years ago we surprised
them we took them by surprise and this
year
they rigged an election they rigged it
like they've never rigged an election
before and by the way
last night they didn't do a bad job
either if you notice
i'm honest and and i just again i want
to thank you it's uh just a great honor
to have this kind of
crowd and to be before you and
hundreds of thousands of american
patriots are committed to
the honesty of our elections and the
integrity
of our glorious republic all of us here
today
do not want to see your election victory
stolen by emboldened radical left
democrats which is what they're doing
and stolen by the fake news media that's
what they've done and what they're doing
we will never give up we will never
concede it doesn't happen you don't
concede when there's theft
[Applause]
our country has had enough we will not
take it anymore and that's what this is
all about
and to use a favorite term that all of
you people really came up with
we will stop the steal
[Applause]
today i will lay out just some of the
evidence proving that we won this
election
and we won it by a landslide this was
not a close election
you know i say sometimes jokingly but
there's no
joke about it i've been in two elections
i won them both
and the second one i won much bigger
than the first okay
almost 75 million people voted for our
campaign the most of any incumbent
president
by far in the history of our country 12
million more people than four years ago
and i was told by the real pollsters we
do have real pulses they know that
we were going to do well and we were
going to win but i was told if i went
from 63 million which we had
four years ago to 66 billion
there was no chance of losing well we
didn't go to 66
we went to 75 million and they say we
lost we didn't lose
and by the way does anybody believe that
joe
had 80 million votes does anybody
believe that
he had 80 million computer votes
it's a disgrace there's never been
anything like that
you could take third world countries
just take a look take
third world countries their elections
are more honest than what we've been
going through in this country
it's a disgrace it's a disgrace even
when you look at last night
they're all running around like chickens
with their heads cut off with
boxes and nobody knows what the hell is
going on there's never been anything
like this
we will not let them silence your voices
we're not gonna let it happen
not gonna let it happen
thank you
and i'd love to have if those tens of
thousands of people would be allowed
the military the secret service and we
want to thank you and the police law
enforcement great you're doing a great
job
but i'd love it if they could be allowed
to come up here with us
is that possible can you just let them
come up please
and rudy you did a great job
he's got guts you know what he's got
guts unlike a lot of people in the
republican party
he's got guts he fights he fights and
i'll tell you thank you very much john
fantastic job i watched
that's a tough act to follow those two
john is one of the most brilliant
lawyers in the country and he looked at
this and he said
what an absolute disgrace that this
could be happening to our constitution
and he looked at mike pence and i hope
mike is going to do the right thing i
hope so
i hope so because if mike pence does the
right thing
we win the election all he has to do
all in this is this is from the number
one or certainly one of the top
constitutional lawyers in our country he
has the absolute right to do it
we're supposed to protect our country
support our country
support our constitution and protect our
constitution
states want to revoke the states
got defrauded they were given false
information
they voted on it now they want to
recertify
they want it back all vice president
pence has to do
is send it back to the states to
recertify
and we become president and you are the
happiest people
[Applause]
and i actually i just spoke to mike i
said mike that doesn't take courage
what takes courage is to do nothing
that takes courage and then we're stuck
with a president
who lost the election by a lot and we
have to live with that
for four more years we're just not going
to let that happen many of you
have traveled from all across the nation
to be here and i want to thank you for
the
extraordinary love that's what it is
there's never been a movement like this
ever
ever for the extraordinary love for this
amazing country
and this amazing movement thank you
by the way this goes all the way back
past the washington monument do you
believe this look at this
they gave the press the prime seats i
can't stand that
no but you look at that behind i wish
they'd flip those cameras and look
behind you
that is the most amazing sight
when they make a mistake you get to see
it on television
amazing amazing all the way back
and don't worry we will not take the
name off
the washington monument we will cancel
culture
you know they wanted to uh get rid of
the jefferson memorial
either take it down or just put somebody
else in there i don't think that's going
to happen
it damn well better not although with
this administration if this happens
it could happen you'll see some really
bad things happen
they'll knock out lincoln too by the way
they've been taking his statue down but
then we signed a little law
you hurt our monuments you hurt our
heroes you go to jail for 10 years and
everything stopped you notice that
it stopped it all stopped
and they could use rudy back in new york
city rudy
they could use you your city's going to
hell
they want rudy giuliani back in new york
we'll get a little younger version of
rudy is that okay rudy
we're gathered together in the heart of
our nation's capital for one very
very basic and simple reason
to save our democracy
you know most candidates on election
evening and of course
this thing goes on so long they still
don't have any idea what the votes are
we still have congressional seats
under review they have no idea they've
totally lost control
they've used the pandemic as a way of
defrauding the people
in a proper election but you know
you know when you see this and when you
see what's happening
number one they also sir we'll never let
it happen again i said that's good but
what about eight weeks ago you know they
try and get you to go
they said sir in four years you're
guaranteed i said i'm not interested
right now do me a favor go back
eight weeks i want to go back eight
weeks let's go back eight weeks
we want to go back and we want to get
this right because we're
to have somebody in there that should
not be in there and our country
will be destroyed and we're not going to
stand for that
for years democrats have gotten away
with election fraud and
weak republicans and that's what they
are there's so many weak republicans and
we have great ones jim jordan and some
of these guys they're out there fighting
the house guys are fighting
but it's uh it's incredible many of the
republicans i help them get in i help
them get elected
i helped mitch get elected i helped
i could name 24 of them
let's say i won't bore you with it and
then all of a sudden you have something
like this that is like oh
gee maybe i'll talk to the president
sometime later
no it's amazing the weak republicans
they're pathetic republicans and that's
what happens
if this happened to the democrats
there'd be hell
all over the country going on there'd be
hell
all over the country but just remember
this you're stronger
you're smarter you've got more going
than anybody
and they try and demean everybody having
to do with us
and you're the real people you're the
people that built this nation
you're not the people that tore down our
nation
the weak republicans and that's it i
really believe it i think i'm going to
use the term the weak republicans you've
got a lot of them and you've got a lot
of great ones but you've got a lot of
weak ones
they've turned to bly eye even as
democrats enacted policies
that chipped away our jobs weakened our
military
threw open our borders and put america
last
did you see the other day where joe
biden said i want to get rid of the
america first policy what's that all
about get rid of
how do you say i want to get rid of
america first
even if you're gonna do it don't talk
about it right
unbelievable what we have to go through
what we have to go through and you have
to get your people
to fight and if they don't fight we have
to primary the hell out of the ones that
don't
fight we primary them we're gonna we're
gonna let you know who they are i can
already tell you frankly
but this year using the pretext of the
china virus
and the scam of mail-in ballots
democrats attempted the most brazen and
outrageous election
theft and there's never been anything
like this it's a pure theft
in american history everybody knows it
that election our election
was over at 10 o'clock in the evening
we're leading
pennsylvania michigan georgia
by hundreds of thousands of votes and
then
late in the evening or early in the
morning
boom these explosions of [ __ ] and
all of a sudden
all of a sudden it started to happen
don't forget when romney got beat romney
did you see his i wonder if he enjoyed
his flight in last night
but when romney got beaten you know he
stands up like
you're more typical well i'd like to
congratulate
the victor the victor who is the victor
mitt
i'd like to congratulate they don't go
and look at the facts no i don't know
he got he got slaughtered probably maybe
it was okay
maybe it was that's what happened but we
look at the facts
and our election was so corrupt that in
the history of this country we've never
seen anything like
it you can go all the way back you know
america
is blessed with elections all over the
world they talk about our elections you
know what the world says about us now
they say we don't have free and fair
elections and you know what else we
don't have a free
and fair press our media is not free
it's not fair it suppresses thought
it suppresses speech and it's become
the enemy of the people it's become the
enemy of the people it's a it's the
biggest problem we have in this country
no third world countries would even
attempt
to do what we caught them doing
and you'll hear about that in just a few
minutes republicans are
republicans are constantly fighting like
a boxer
with his hands tied behind his back it's
like a boxer
and we want to be so nice
we want to be so respectful of everybody
including
bad people and we're going to have to
fight much harder
and mike pence is going to have to come
through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
because you're sworn to uphold
our constitution
now it is up to congress to confront
this egregious assault
on our democracy and after this
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down anyone you want
but i think right here we're going to
walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength and you have to be
strong
have come to demand that congress do the
right thing
and only count the electors who have
been lawfully
slated lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
today we will see whether republicans
stand
strong for integrity of our elections
but whether or not they stand strong for
our country
our country our country has been under
siege for a long time
far longer than this four year period
we've set it
on a much straighter course a much and
we i thought
you know four more years i thought it
would be easy we created the greatest
economy in history we rebuilt our
military
we get you the biggest tax cuts in
history
right we got you the biggest regulation
cuts there's no president whether it's
four years eight years or in one case
more
got anywhere near the regulation cuts
used to take 20 years to get a highway
approved
now we're down to two i want to get it
down to one
but we're down to two and it may get
rejected for environmental or safety
reasons
but we got it down to safety we created
space force we
look at what we did our military has
been totally rebuilt
so we create space force which by and of
itself
is a major achievement for an
administration
and with us it's one of so many
different things
right to try everybody know about right
to try we did things
that nobody ever thought possible we
took care of our vets
our vets the va now has the highest
rating 91
the highest rating that it's had
from the beginning 91 approval rated
always you watch the va it was on
television every night people
living in a horrible horrible manner
we got that done we got accountability
done
we got it so that now in the va you
don't have to wait for four weeks six
weeks eight weeks
four months to see a doctor if you can't
get a doctor you go outside you get the
doctor
you have them taken care of and we pay
the doctor
and we've not only made life wonderful
for so many people
we've saved tremendous amounts of money
far secondarily but we've saved a lot of
money
and now we have the right to fire bad
people in the va we had 9 000
people that treated our veterans
horribly
in prime time they would not have
treated our veterans badly
but they treated our veterans horribly
and we have what's called the account of
a va
accountability act and the
accountability says
if we see somebody in there that doesn't
treat our vets well or they steal
they rob they do things badly we say joe
you're fired get out of here before you
couldn't do that
you couldn't do that before so we've
taken care of things we've done things
like nobody's ever thought possible
and that's part of the reason that many
people don't like us
because we've done too much but we've
done it quickly
and we were going to sit home and watch
a big victory and everybody had us down
for a victory it was going to be great
and now we're out here fighting i said
to somebody i was going to take a few
days and relax
after our big electoral victory 10
o'clock it was over
but i was going to take a few days and i
can say this
since our election i believe
which was such a catastrophe when i
watched and even these guys knew what
happened they know what happened
they're saying wow pennsylvania's
insurmountable
wow wisconsin look at the big leads we
had right
even though the press said we lose
wisconsin by 17 points
even though the press said ohio's going
to be close
we set a record florida's going to be
close we set a record
texas is going to be close texas is
going to be close we set a record
and we set a record with hispanic with
the black community we set a record with
everybody
today we see a very important event
though because right over there
right there we see the event going to
take place
and i'm going to be watching because
history is going to be made
we're going to see whether or not we
have great and courageous leaders or
whether or not
we have leaders that should be ashamed
of themselves
throughout history throughout eternity
they'll be ashamed
and you know what if they do the wrong
thing
we should never ever forget that they
did
never forget we should never ever forget
with only three of the seven states in
question
we win the presidency of the united
states
and by the way it's much more important
today
than it was 24 hours ago because
and don't i spoke to david perdue what a
great person
and kelly lefler two great people but it
was a setup
and you know i said we have no
back line anymore the only back line the
only
line of demarcation the only line that
we have
is the veto of the president of the
united states
so this is now what we're doing a far
more important election
than it was two days ago i want to thank
the more than 140 members of the house
those are warriors
they're over there working like you've
never seen before
studying talking actually going all the
way back studying the roots of the
constitution
because they know we have the right to
send a bad vote
that was illegally gotten they gave
these people
bad things to vote for and they voted
because what did they know and then when
they found out a few weeks later
again it took them four years to devise
this screen
and the only unhappy person in the
united states single most
unhappy is hillary clinton because she
said why didn't you do this for me four
years ago
why didn't you do this for me four years
ago
change the votes 10 000 in michigan
you could have changed the whole thing
but she's not too happy you notice she
you don't see her anymore what happened
where's hillary
where is she but i want to thank
all of those congressmen and women
i also want to thank our 13 most
courageous members of the u.s senate
senator ted cruz senator ron johnson
senator josh hawley kelly laflin
and kelly left i'll tell you she has
been
she's been so great she worked so hard
so
let's give her and david a little
special head because it was rigged
against him let's give her
and david kelly left david
they fought a good race they never had a
shot
that equipment should never have been
allowed to be used and i was telling
these people
don't let them use this stuff marsha
blackburn terrific person mike braun
indiana
steve dames great guy bill hagerty
john kennedy james lankford cynthia
lumps
tommy tuberville to the coach and roger
marshall we want to thank them senators
have stepped up we want to thank them
i actually think though it takes again
more courage
not to step up and i think a lot of
those people are going to find that out
and you better start looking at your
leadership because your leadership has
led you down the tubes
you know we don't want to give two
thousand dollars to people we want to
give them six hundred dollars oh great
how does that play politically pretty
good and this has nothing to do with
politics
but how does it play politically china
destroyed these people we didn't disrupt
china destroyed them totally destroyed
them
we want to give them six hundred dollars
and they just wouldn't change
i said give them two thousand dollars
we'll pay it back
we'll pay it back fast you already owe
26 trillion
give them a couple of bucks let them
live give them a couple of bucks
and some of the people here disagree
with me on that but i just say
look you got to let people live and how
does that play though okay number one
it's the right thing to do
but how does that play politically i
think it's the primary reason one of the
primary reasons
the other was just pure cheating that
was the primary super primary reason
but you can't do that got to use your
head as you know the media has
constantly asserted the outrageous lie
that there was
no evidence of widespread food you ever
see these people
while there is no evidence of fraud or
really
well i'm going to read you pages i hope
you don't get bored listening to it
promise
don't get bored listening to it all
those hundreds of thousands of people
back there
move them up please yeah all the
all these people don't get bored don't
get angry at me because you're gonna get
bored
because it's so much the american people
do not believe
the corrupt fake news anymore they have
ruined their reputation
but you know it used to be that they'd
argue with me i'd fight so i'd fight
that fight i'd fight that fight pop up
you'd believe me you'd believe
them somebody comes out you know they
had their point of view i had my point
of view
but you'd have an argument now what they
do is they go silent
it's called depression and that's what
happens
in a communist country that's what they
do they suppress
you don't fight with them anymore unless
it's a bad serve they have a little bad
story about me they make it ten times
worse and it's a major headline
but hunter biden they don't talk about
him what happened to hunter where's
where is hunter they don't talk about
them
now watch all the sets will go off well
they can't do that because they get good
ratings
their ratings are too good now where's
hunter
you know and and how come joe was
allowed to
give a billion dollars of money to get
rid of the prosecutor in ukraine how
does that happen
i'd ask you that question how does that
happen can you imagine if i've said that
if i said that it would be a whole
different ballgame
and how come hunter gets three and a
half million dollars from
the mayor of moscow's wife and gets
hundreds
of thousands of dollars to sit on an
energy board even though he admits he
has
no knowledge of energy and millions of
dollars up front
and how come they go into china and they
leave with billions of dollars to manage
have you managed money before no i
haven't oh that's good here's about
three billion
no they don't talk about that no we have
a corrupt media
they've gone silent they've gone dead i
now realize
how good it was if you go back 10 years
i realized
how good even though i didn't
necessarily
love him i realized how it was like a
cleansing motion right
but we don't have that anymore we don't
have
a fair media anymore it's suppression
and you have to be very careful with
that
and they've lost all credibility in this
country we will not
be intimidated into accepting the hoaxes
and the lies
that we've been forced to believe over
the past several weeks we've amassed
overwhelming evidence about a fake
election
this is the presidential election last
night was a little bit better because of
the fact that we had a lot of eyes
watching one specific state
but they cheated like hell anyway you
have one of the dumbest governors in the
united states
and you know when i endorsed him
i didn't know this guy at the request of
david perdue said friend of mine's
running for governor what's his name
and you know the rest he was in fourth
place
fifth place i don't know he was wait he
was doing poorly
i endorsed him he went like a rocket
ship that he won
and then i had to beat stacey abrams
with this guy
brian kemp i had to beat stacy abrams
and i had to beat oprah used to be a
friend of mine you know i was on her
last show or last week
she picked the five outstanding people i
don't think she thinks that anymore
once i ran for president i didn't notice
there were too many calls coming in from
oprah
believe it or not she used to like me
but i was one of the five outstanding
people
and i had a campaign against michelle
obama
and barack hussein obama against stacey
and i had brian kemp he weighs 130
pounds he said he played offensive line
in football i'm trying to figure that
out
i'm still trying to figure that out so
that the other night i was his
offensive lineman i'm saying really that
must have been a very small team
but i look at that and i look at what's
happened
and he turned out to be a disaster this
stuff happens you know
look i'm not happy with the supreme
court they love to rule against me i
picked three
people i fought like hell for them one
in particular i thought
they all said sir cut him loose he's
killing the senators you know very loyal
senators they're very loyal people
sir cut him loose he's killing us sir
cut him loose sir
i must have gotten half of the senators
i said no i can't do that it's unfair to
him and it's unfair to the family
he didn't do anything wrong they made up
stories they were all made up stories he
didn't do anything wrong
caught a blue sir i said no i won't do
that we got them through
and you know what they couldn't give a
damn they couldn't give a damn
let them rule the right way but it
almost seems that they're all going out
of their way to hurt all of us
and to hurt our country to hurt our
country
you know i read a story in one of the
newspapers recently
how i control the three supreme court
justices i control them
they're puppets i read it about bill
barr that he's my personal attorney
that he'll do anything for me and i said
you know it really is
genius because what they do is that and
it makes it really impossible for them
to ever give you a victory
because all of a sudden billboard
changed if you hadn't noticed
i like bill barr but he changed because
he didn't want to be considered
my personal attorney and the supreme
court
they rule against me so much you know
why because the story is
i haven't spoken to any of them any of
them
since virtually they got in but the
story is
that they're my puppet right that
they're puppets
and now the only way they can get out of
that because they hate that it's not
good on the social circuit
and the only way they get out is to rule
against trump
so let's rule against trump and they do
that so i want to congratulate
them but it shows you the media's genius
in fact probably if i was the media i'd
do it the same way i hate to say it
but we got to get them straightened out
today for the sake of our democracy
for the sake of our constitution and for
the sake of our children
we lay out the case for the entire world
to hear
do you want to hear it in every single
swing set
local officials state officials almost
all democrats
made illegal and unconstitutional
changes
to election procedures without the
mandated approvals by the state
legislatures
that these changes pave the way for
fraud or to scale
never seen before and i think we can go
a long way outside of our country when i
say that
so just in a nutshell you can't make a
change
on voting for a federal election unless
the state legislature approves it no
judge can do it nobody can do it only a
legislature
so as an example in pennsylvania or
whatever
you have a republican legislature you
have a democrat mayor
and you have a lot of democrats all over
the place they go to the legislature
the legislature laughs at them says
we're not going to do that
they say thank you very much and they go
and make the changes themselves they do
it anyway
and that's totally illegal that's
totally illegal you can't do that
in pennsylvania the democrat secretary
of state
and the democrat state supreme court
justices
illegally abolished the signature
verification requirements
just 11 days prior to the election so
think of what they did
no longer is their signature
verification oh that's okay
we want voter id by the way but no
longer is there signature verification
11 days before the election they say we
don't want it
you know why they don't want to because
they want to cheat that's the only
reason
who wouldn't even think of that we don't
want to verify a signature
there were over 205 000 more ballots
counted in pennsylvania think of this
you had 205 000
more ballots than you had voters
that means you had two where did they
come from you know where they came from
somebody's imagination whatever they
needed
so in pennsylvania you had 205
000 more votes than you had voters
and it's the number's actually much
greater than that now
that was as of a week ago and this is a
mathematical impossibility unless you
want to say
it's a total fraud so pennsylvania was
defrauded
over 8 000 ballots in pennsylvania were
cast by people
whose names and dates of birth match
individuals who died
in 2020 and prior to the election
think of that dead people lots of dead
people thousands
and some dead people actually requested
an application that bothers me
not only are they voting they want an
application to vote
one of them was 29 years ago died
it's incredible over 14 000 ballots were
cast
by out of state voters so these are
voters that don't live in the state
and by the way these numbers are
what they call outcome determinative
meaning these numbers far surpass i lost
by a very little bit
these numbers are massive massive more
than 10
000 votes in pennsylvania were illegally
counted
even though they were received after
elected day in other words
they were received after election day
let's count them anyway
and what they did in many cases is they
did fraud
they took the date and they moved it
back so that it no longer is after
election day
and more than 60 000 ballots in
pennsylvania
were reported received back they got
back
before they were ever supposedly mailed
out in other words you got the ballot
back before you mailed it
which is also
logically and logistically impossible
right
think of that one you got the ballot
back let's send the ballot so they've
already been sent
but we got the ballot back before they
were sent i don't think that's too good
right
25 000 ballots in pennsylvania were
requested by nursing home residents
all in a single giant batch not legal
indicating an enormous illegal ballot
harvesting operation
you're not allowed to do it's against
the law the day before the election the
state of pennsylvania reported the
number of absentee ballots
that had been sent out yet this number
was suddenly
and drastically increased by 400
000 people it was increased
nobody knows where it came from by 400
000
ballots one day after the election
it remains totally unexplained they said
well we can't
uh figure that now that's many many
times what it would take to overthrow
the state just that one element
400 000 ballots appeared from nowhere
right after the election by the way
pennsylvania
has now seen all of this they didn't
know because it was so quick
they had to vote they voted but now they
see all this stuff it's all come to life
it doesn't happen that fast and they
want to
re-certify their votes they want to
re-certify
but the only way that can happen is if
mike pence agrees to send it back
mike pence has to agree to send it back
and many people in congress want to send
back and think of what you're doing
let's say you don't do it somebody says
well we have to obey the constitution
and you are
because you're protecting our country
and you're protecting the constitution
so you are
but think of what happens let's say
they're stiffs
and they're stupid people and they say
well we really have no choice even
though pennsylvania and other states
want to redo their votes
they want to see the numbers they
already have numbers
go very quickly and they want to redo
their legislature
because many of these votes were taken
as i said because it wasn't approved by
their legislature you know
that in itself is legal and then you
have the scam
and that's all of the things that we're
talking about but think of this
if you don't do that that means you will
have
a president of the united states for
four years with his wonderful son
you will have a president
who lost all of these states or
you will have a president to put it
another way who
was voted on by a bunch of stupid people
who lost all of these states you will
have an illegitimate
president that's what you'll have and we
can't let that happen
these are the facts that you won't hear
from the fake news media it's all part
of the
suppression effort they don't want to
talk about it they don't want to talk
about it
in fact when i started talking about
that i guarantee you a lot of the
television sets
and a lot of those cameras went off and
that's a lot of cameras back there
but a lot of them went off but these are
the things you don't
hear about you don't hear what you just
heard and i'm going to go over
a few more states but you don't hear it
by the people
who want to deceive you and demoralize
you and control you big tech
media just like the suppression polls
that said
we're gonna lose wisconsin by 17 points
well we won wisconsin they don't have it
that way
because it was just by a little sliver
they had me down the day before
washington post abc paul
down 17 points i called up a real
pollster i said what is that
sir that's called a suppression poll i
think you're going to win wisconsin sir
i said but why don't they make it four
or five points because then people vote
but when you're down 17 they say hey i'm
not going to waste my time i love the
president but there's no way
despite that despite that we
won wisconsin it's going to see i mean
you'll see
but that's called suppression because a
lot of people when they see that
it's very interesting this pulse has
said sir if you're down three four five
people vote when you go down 17 they say
let's save let's go and have dinner and
let's watch the presidential defeat
tonight on television darling
and just like the radical left tries to
blacklist you
on social media every time i put out a
tweet
that's even if it's totally correct
totally correct
i get a flag i get a flag
and they also don't let you get out you
know on twitter it's very hard to come
onto my account
it's very hard to get out a message they
don't let the message get out
nearly like they should but i've had
many people say i can't get on your
twitter
i don't care about twitter twitter's bad
news they're all bad news
but you know what if you want to if you
want to get out of message
and if you want to go through big tech
social media
they are really if you're a conservative
if you're a republican if you have a big
voice
i guess they call it shadow band right
shadow band the shadow man you
and it should be illegal i've been
telling these republicans get rid of
section 230
and for some reason mitch and the group
they don't want to put it in there
and they don't realize that that's going
to be the end of the republican party as
we know it but it's never going to be
the end of us
never let them get out
let let the weak ones get out this is a
time for strength
they also want to indoctrinate your
children in school
by teaching them things that aren't so
they want to indoctrinate your children
it's all part of the
comprehensive assault on our democracy
and the american people are finally
standing up
and saying no this crowd is again a
testament to it i did no advertising i
did nothing
you do have some groups that are big
supporters i want to thank that amy and
everybody
we have some incredible supporters
incredible
but we didn't do anything this just
happened two months ago
we had a massive crowd come down to
washington i said what are they there
for
sir they're there for you we have
nothing to do with it
these groups are for they're forming all
over the united states and we got to
remember
in a year from now you're going to start
working on
congress and we got to get rid of the
weak congress people the ones that
aren't any good
the liz cheney's of the world we got to
get rid of them
we got to get rid you know she never
wants a soldier brought home
20 i brought a lot of our soldiers home
i don't know somewhat
like it they're in countries that nobody
even knows the name nobody knows where
they are
they're dying they're great but they're
dying
they're losing their arms their legs
their face
i brought them back home largely back
home afghanistan
iraq remember i used to say in the old
days don't go
to wreck but if you go and keep the oil
we didn't keep the oil
so stupid so stupid these people
and iraq has billions and billions of
dollars now in the bank
and what did we do we get nothing we
never get but we do
actually we kept the oil here or we can
we did good we got rid of
the isis caliphate we got rid of plenty
of different things that
everybody knows and the rebuilding of
our military in three years
people said it couldn't be done and it
was all made in the usa
all made in the usa best equipment in
the world
in wisconsin corrupt democrat-run cities
deployed more than 500 illegal unmanned
unsecured drop boxes
which collected a minimum of 91 000
unlawful votes it was razor thin the
loss just
one thing alone is much more than we
would need but there are many things
they have these lock boxes and you know
they'd pick them up and they'd disappear
for two days people would say where's
that box
it disappeared nobody even knew where
the hell it was
in addition over 170 000 absentee votes
were counted in wisconsin without a
valid absentee ballot application
so they had a vote but they had no
application and that's illegal
in wisconsin meaning those votes were
blatantly
done in opposition to state law
and became 100 from democrat areas such
as
milwaukee and madison
100 in madison 17
000 votes were deposited in so-called
human drop boxes you know what that is
right where operatives stuff
thousands of unsecured ballots into
duffel bags
on park benches across the city in
complete defiance of cease and desist
letters from state
legislature your state legislature said
don't do it they're the only ones that
can approve it
they gave tens of thousands of votes
they came in in duffel bags
where the hell did they come from
according to eyewitness testimony postal
service workers in wisconsin
were also instructed to illegally
backdate approximately
100 000 ballots the margin of difference
in wisconsin was less than 20 000 votes
each one of these things alone wins us
the state
great state we love the state we won the
state
in georgia your secretary of state
who i can't believe this guy's a
republican he loves recording telephone
conversations you know
that was a i thought it was a great
conversation personally
so did a lot of us people love that
conversation
because it says what's going on these
people are crooked
they're 100 in my opinion one of the
most
between the governor and your secretary
of state and now you have it again
last night just take a look at what
happened what a mess
and the democrat party operators entered
into an illegal
and unconstitutional unconstitutional
settlement agreement
that drastically weakened signature
verification and other
election security procedures stacy
abrams
she took them to lunch and i beat her
two years ago with a bad candidate brian
kell
but they took the democrats took the
republicans to lunch
because the secretary of state had no
clue what the hell was happening
unless he did have a clue that's
interesting maybe he was with the other
side
but we've been trying to get
verifications of signatures
in fulton county they won't let us do it
the only reason they won't is because
we'll find things
in the hundreds of thousands why
wouldn't they let us verify
signatures in fulton county which is
known for being very corrupt
they won't do it they go to some other
county where you would live
i said that's not the problem the
problem is fulton county
home of stacy abrams she did a good job
i congratulate her but it was
done in such a way that we can't let
this stuff happen
we won't have a country if it happens as
a result george's absency ballot
rejection rate
was more than 10 times lower than
previous levels
because the criteria was so
off 48 counties in georgia with
thousands and thousands of votes
rejected
zero ballots there wasn't one ballot
in other words in a year in which more
mail-in ballots were sent than ever
before
and more people were voting by mail for
the first time
the rejection rate was drastically lower
than it had ever been before
the only way this can be explained is if
tens of thousands of illegitimate votes
were added to the tally that's the only
way you could explain it
by the way you're talking about tens of
thousands
if georgia had merely rejected the same
number of unlawful ballots
as in other years there should have been
approximately 45 000
ballots rejected far more than what we
needed to win just over 11 000
they should find those votes they should
absolutely find that
just over 11 000 votes that's all we
need
they defrauded us out of a win in
georgia and we're not going to forget it
there's only one reason the democrats
could possibly want to eliminate
signature matching oppose voter id and
stop
citizenship confirmation are you a
citizenship you're not allowed to ask
that question
because they want to steal the election
the radical left knows exactly what
they're doing
they're ruthless and it's time that
somebody did something about it and mike
pence i hope you're going to stand up
for the good of our constitution and for
the good
of our country and if you're not i'm
going to be very disappointed in you i
will tell you right now
i'm not hearing good stories in fulton
county republican poll watchers were
ejected
in some cases physically from the room
under the false pretense of a pipe
burst water main burst everybody leave
which we now know was a total lie then
election officials pull boxes democrats
and suitcases of ballots out from under
a table you all saw it on television
totally fraudulent and illegally scanned
them
for nearly two hours totally
unsupervised
tens of thousands of votes this act
coincided with a mysterious vote dump
of up to 100 000 votes for joe biden
almost none for trump oh that sounds
fair
that was at 1 34 a.m
the georgia secretary of state and
pathetic
governor of georgia have reached
although he says i'm a great president
you know i sort of maybe have to change
he said the other day
yes i go i disagree with president but
he's been a great president okay thanks
thank you very much because of him and
others yeah brian kemp vote him the hell
out of office please
well his rates are so low you know his
approval rating now
i think it just reached a record low
they've rejected five separate appeals
for an independent and comprehensive
audit of signatures in fulton county
even without an audit the number of
fraudulent ballots that we've identified
across the state
is staggering over 10 300 ballots in
georgia were cast by individuals
whose names and dates at birth match
georgia residents who died
in 2020 and prior to the election
more than 2 500 ballots were cast by
individuals
whose names and dates of birth match
incarcerated felons in georgia prison
people who are not allowed to vote
more than 4 500 illegal ballots were
cast by individuals who do not appear
on the state's own voter rolls over
eighteen
thousand illegal ballots were cast by
individuals who registered to vote
using an address listed as vacant
according to the postal service
at least eighty eight thousand in
georgia were cast by people
whose registrations were illegally
backdated
66 000 votes each one of these is far
more than we need
66 000 votes in georgia were cast by
individuals under the legal voting age
and at least 15 000 ballots were cast by
individuals
who moved out of the state prior to
november third election
they say they moved right back they
moved right back oh they moved out they
moved right back okay
they missed george's that much i do i
love georgia
but it's a corrupt system despite all of
this the margin
in georgia is only 11 779 votes
each and every one of these issues is
enough to give us
a victory in georgia a big beautiful
victory
make no mistake this election was stolen
from you
from me and from the country and not a
single swing state had conducted a
comprehensive audit
to remove the illegal ballots this
should absolutely occur in every single
contested state before the election is
certified
in the state of arizona over 36 000
ballots were illegally cast by
non-citizens
2 000 ballots were returned with no
address
more than 22 000 ballots were returned
before they were
ever supposedly mailed out they returned
but we haven't mailed them yet
11 600 more ballots and votes were
counted
more than there were actual voters you
see that so you have
more votes again than you have voters
150
000 people registered in maya copa
county
after the registration deadline 103
000 ballots in the county were sent for
electronic adjudication with no
republican observers
in clark county nevada the accuracy
settings on signature verification
machines
were purposely lowered before they were
used
to count over 130 000 ballots
if you signed your name as santa claus
it would go through
there were also more than 42 000 double
votes in nevada
over 150 000
people were hurt so badly
by what took place and 1500 ballots were
cast by
individuals whose names and dates of
birth matched nevada residents
who died in 2020 prior to november third
election
more than 8 000 votes were cast by
individuals
who had no address and probably didn't
live there
the margin in nevada is down at a very
low number any of these things would
have taken care of the situation
we would have won nevada also every one
of these were going over we win
in michigan quickly the secretary of
state a real
great one flooded the state with
unsolicited mail-in ballot applications
sent to every person on the rolls in
direct violation of state law
more than 17 000 michigan ballots were
cast by individuals whose names and
dates of birth
match people who were deceased in wayne
county
that's a great one that's detroit
174 000 ballots were counted without
being tied to an
actual registered voter nobody knows
where they came from
also in wayne county poll watches
observed
canvassers rescanning batches of ballots
over and over again up to three or four
or five times in detroit turnout
was 139 of registered voters think of
that
so you had 139 of the people in detroit
voting
this is in michigan detroit michigan a
career employee of the detroit
city of detroit testified under penalty
of perjury that she witnessed city
workers coaching voters to vote
straight democrat while accompanying
them to watch
who they voted for when a republican
came in they wouldn't talk to him
the same worker was instructed not to
ask
for any voter id and not to attempt to
validate any signatures
if they were democrats she also told to
illegally and was told back date ballots
received after the deadline and reports
that thousands and thousands of ballots
were improperly backdated that's
michigan
four witnesses have testified under
penalty of perjury
that after officials in detroit
announced the last votes
had been counted tens of thousands of
additional ballots arrive
without required envelopes every single
one
was for a democrat i got no votes
at 6 31 a.m in the early morning hours
after
voting had ended michigan suddenly
reported 147
000 votes an astounding 94
went to joe biden who campaigned
brilliantly from his basement
only a couple of percentage points went
to trump
such gigantic and one-sided vote dumps
were only observed in a few sling states
and they were observed in the states
where it was necessary you know what's
interesting
president obama beat biden
in every state other than the swing
states where biden killed them but the
swing states were the ones that mattered
they're always just enough to push joe
biden barely into the lead
we were ahead by a lot and within a
number of hours we were losing by
a little in addition there is the highly
troubling matter of dominion voting
systems
in one michigan county alone 6 000
votes were switched from trump to biden
and the same systems are used in the
majority of
states in our country
senator william
liggin a great gentleman chairman of
georgia senate judiciary subcommittee
senator liggin highly respected on
elections has written a letter
describing his concerns with dominion in
georgia
he wrote and i quote the dominion voting
machines employed in fulton county
had an astronomical and astounding 93.67
error rate it's only wrong 93 of the
time
in the scanning of ballots requiring a
review panel to adjudicate or determine
the voters interest
in over 106 000 ballots out of a total
of 113 000. think of it
you go in and you vote and then they
tell people who you're supposed to be
voting for they
make up whatever they want nobody's ever
even heard they adjudicate your vote
they say well we don't think trump wants
to vote for trump
we think he wants to vote for biden put
it down for by the national average for
such an error rate
is far less than one percent and yet
you're at 93
the source of this astronomical error
rate must be identified to determine
if these machines were set up or
destroyed to allow for a third party to
disregard
the actual ballot cast by the registered
voter
the letter continues there is clear
evidence that tens of thousands of votes
were switched from president trump to
former vice president biden
in several counties in georgia for
example in bibb county president trump
was reported to have 29
391 votes at 9
11 p.m eastern time while simultaneously
vice president
joe biden was reported to have seventeen
thousand two thirteen
minutes later just minutes at the next
update these vote numbers
switched with president trump going way
down to seventeen thousand
and biden going way up to twenty nine
thousand three ninety one
and that was very quick a twelve
thousand vote switch
all in mr biden's favor so i mean i
could go on and on
about this fraud that took place in
every state
and all of these legislatures want this
back
i don't want to do it to you because i
love you and it's freezing out here
but i could just go on forever i can
tell you this
so when you hear when you hear
while there is no evidence to prove any
wrongdoing
this is the most fraudulent thing
anybody said this is a criminal
enterprise
this is a criminal enterprise and and
the press will
say and i'm sure they won't put any of
that on there because that's no good
have you ever seen while there is no
evidence to back
president trump's assertion i could go
on for
another hour reading this stuff to you
and telling you about it
there's never been anything like it
think about it
detroit had more votes than it had
voters
pennsylvania had 205 000
more votes than it had more but you
don't have to go any
that between that i think that's almost
better than dead people if you think
right more votes than the head voters
and many other states also
it's a disgrace that the united states
of america tens of millions of people
are allowed to go vote without so much
as even
showing identification in no state is
there any
question or effort
made to verify the identity citizenship
residency or eligibility of the votes
cast
the republicans have to get tougher
you're not going to have a republican
party if you don't get tougher
they want to play so straight they want
to play souls sir yes the united states
the constitution doesn't allow me to
send them back to this state
well i say yes it does because the
constitution says you have to protect
our country
and you have to protect our constitution
and you can't vote on fraud and fraud
breaks up
everything doesn't it when you catch
somebody in a fraud
you're allowed to go by very different
rules
so i hope mike has the courage to do
what he has to do
and i hope he doesn't listen to the
rhinos and the stupid people that he's
listening to
it is also widely understood that the
voter roles are
crammed full of non-citizens felons and
people who have moved out of state
and individuals who are otherwise
ineligible to vote
yet democrats oppose every effort to
clean up their voter rolls they don't
want to clean them up
they're loaded and how many people here
know other people that when the hundreds
of thousands and then millions of
ballots got sent out
got three four five six and i heard one
who got seven ballots
and then they say you didn't quite make
it sir
uh we we won in a landslide this was a
landslide
they said it's not american to challenge
the election this is the most corrupt
election in the history maybe of the
world
you know you could go third world
countries but i don't think they had
hundreds of thousands of votes and they
don't have voters for them i mean no
matter where you go
nobody would think this in fact it's so
egregious it's so bad that a lot of
people don't even believe it it's so
crazy
that people don't even believe it it
can't be true
so they don't believe it this is not
just a matter of
domestic politics this is a matter of
national security
so today in addition to challenging the
certification of the election i'm
calling on congress and the state
legislatures
to quickly pass sweeping election
reforms and you better do it before we
have no country left
today is not the end it's just the
beginning
with your help over the last four years
we built the greatest political movement
in the history of our country and nobody
even challenges that
i say that over and over and i never get
challenged by the fake news
and they challenge almost everything we
say
but our fight against the big donors big
media big tech and others
is just getting started this is the
greatest in history there's never been a
movement like that you look back there
all the way
to the washington monument it's hard to
believe
we must stop this deal and then we must
ensure
that such outrageous election fraud
never happens again can never be allowed
to happen again
but we're going forward we'll take care
of going forward we got to take care of
going back
don't let them talk okay well we promise
i've had a lot of people
sir you're at 96 for four years
i said i'm not interested right now i'm
interested in right there
with your help we will finally pass
powerful
requirements for voter id you need an id
to cash your check
you need an id to go to a bank to buy
alcohol to drive a car
every person should need to show an id
in order to cast your most important
thing a vote
we will also require proof of american
citizenship in order to vote
in american elections
we just had a good victory in court on
that one actually
we will ban ballot harvesting and
prohibit the use of
unsecured drop boxes to commit rampant
fraud these drop boxes are fraudulent
they're afraid they get they disappear
and then all of a sudden they show up
it's fraudulent we will stop the
practice of universal
unsolicited mail-in balloting we will
clean up the voter rolls that ensure
that every single person who casts a
vote
is a citizen of our country a resident
of the state in which they vote
and their vote is cast at a lawful and
honest manner
we will restore the vital civic
tradition
of in-person voting on election day so
that voters can be fully informed when
they make their choice
we will finally hold big tech
accountable and if these people had
courage and guts
they would get rid of section 230
something that no other company no other
person in america
in the world has
all of these tech monopolies are going
to
abuse their power and interfere in our
elections
and it has to be stopped and the
republicans have to get a lot tougher
and so should the democrats
they should be regulated investigated
and brought to justice
under the fullest extent of the law
they're totally breaking the law
together we will drain the washington
swamp and we will
clean up the corruption in our nation's
capital
we have done a big job on it but you
think it's easy it's a dirty business
it's a dirty business you have a lot of
bad people out there
despite everything we've been through
looking out all over
this country and seeing fantastic crowds
although this i think is our all-time
record
i think you have 250 000 people
250 000 looking out at all the amazing
patriots here today
i have never been more confident in our
nation's future
well i have to say we have to be a
little bit careful that's a nice
statement but we have to be a little
careful with that statement
if we allow this group of people
to illegally take over our country
because it's illegal when the votes
are illegal when the way they got there
is illegal
when the states that vote are given
false and fraudulent information
we are the greatest country on earth
and we are headed and we're headed in
the right direction you know the wall is
built
we're doing record numbers at the wall
now they want to take down the wall
let's let everyone float
that's on everybody flower
we did a great job in the wall remember
the wall they said it could never be
done one of the largest
infrastructure projects we've ever had
in this country
and it's had a tremendous impact that we
got rid of catch and release we got rid
of all of the stuff that we had to live
with
but now the caravans they think biden's
getting in the caravans are forming
again
they want to come in again and rip off
our country can't let it happen
as this enormous crowd shows we have
truth
and justice on our side we have a deep
and enduring love for
america in our hearts we love our
country we have overwhelming pride in
this great country and
we have it deep in our souls together we
are determined to defend and preserve
government
of the people by the people and for the
people
our brightest days are before us
our greatest achievements still wait i
think one of our great achievements
will be election security because nobody
until i came along
had any idea how corrupt our elections
were
and again most people would stand there
at nine o'clock
in the evening and say i want to thank
you very much
and they go off to some other life but i
said
something's wrong here something's
really wrong can't have happened
and we fight we fight like hell and if
you don't fight like hell
you're not gonna have a country anymore
our exciting adventures and boldest
endeavors
have not yet begun my fellow americans
for our movement
for our children and for our beloved
country
and i say this despite all that's
happened
the best is yet to come
so we're going to
we're going to walk down pennsylvania
avenue i love pennsylvania
and we're going to the capitol and we're
going to try and give
the democrats are hopeless they're never
voting for anything
not even one vote but we're going to try
and give
our republicans the weak ones because
the strong ones don't need any of our
help
we're going to try and give them the
kind of pride
and boldness that they need to take back
our country
so let's walk down pennsylvania avenue
i want to thank you all god bless you
and god
bless america thank you all for being
here this is incredible thank you very
much
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
uh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
wow
oh